[Music]
say hi a Miley Cyrus and Entertainment
Tonight we go way back
this is Miley we were on the farm with
Billy Ray and the Cyrus fam all the way
back in 1996 ten years before Miley
would become a star on Hannah Montana
[Applause]
that was so much fun since then we've
seen Miley go through quite the
transformation because I feel like I'm
gonna have like so many different
chapters of my life and you know it's
important to like you know really fill
the fans in and relate to them in 2009
Miley was sharing her soul at one of her
very first book signings this just one
year before her first big image revamp
[Music]
I can't be
I mean life is just too short to be
stressed about what other people say in
2010
Miley met her future fiance Liam
Hemsworth on the set of the last song
[Music]
and released a new album I finally feel
like I feel comfortable and Who I am and
I'm happy to be here I came in
[Music]
I think people try to make me seem a lot
less centered than I am Miley took
things in an entirely new direction with
bangers in 2014 and she made plenty of
headlines along the way I feel like I
got to kind of do
so like soul-searching in a way of what
did I want my music to mean what I kind
of want my life to mean and I didn't
want to just to be about highs and I
thought if I have all this attention on
me and if I'm gonna sell something if we
were going to rush to get it I wanted to
kind of mean something amid all that
hype
Miley took some time to give back
mentoring aspiring artists as a coach on
the voice and launching her happy hippie
foundation
money buddy you
[Music]
to go from you know the Hannah Montana
to the Miley Cyrus that we know now the
craziest maybe evolution ever but I
don't know that she's anybody can say
she's made a wrong move and do anything
I don't think then when you look at her
career and the success he's had other
than just go respect respect a longtime
friend of Billy Ray Blake Shelton has
always had Miley's back so has her
godmother
Dolly Parton I've always said no matter
what you think about it she is so
talented and she is so natural you know
what I'm not one of the people that go
not what you see on TV because I am
exactly kind of who you see on TV
I'm who I am and you see what I'm doing
and I'll never say I'm so sorry I didn't
mean that you know and it's it's you
make choices and sometimes their rights
and eyes are wrong cos like in life
minors magnified what is the future hold
for Miley well new music and yes another
side of the superstar
[Music]